good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday if you've
been following the news at all recently
you know that vladimir putin is just
seconds away from invading our ancient
ally our closest friend of the world
stage that would be the sovereign nation
of ukraine
in response to this news lovers of
democracy everywhere are horrified
this is a slow motion disaster
in effect it's the first domino
first the russians come from ukraine
next it's bangor boise bakersfield what
vladimir putin plans next will make red
dawn look like a documentary so of
course defenders of democracy everywhere
are horrified by this and they're ready
to fight
now nato whose job it apparently is to
contain russia has not yet committed to
defending ukraine for some reason
but patriotic americans are not waiting
for nato that's not their way
according to a piece in buzzfeed
american citizens are joining the fight
on their own it's their spanish civil
war they're paying their way to ukraine
to defend the noble ukrainian people
against the dastardly russian hordes on
the frozen step
but strangely and this is weird
we have no confirmation tonight that
david frum max boot and liz cheney have
left yet for kiev
maybe they're still oiling their rifles
and gathering their kit
or maybe they've decided to man the
cable news barricades just because
they're technically behind the lines
doesn't make their service less perilous
or important and someday they're all
going to get medals for the sacrifices
they're now making in cnn studios in new
york city and we plan to cover that
ceremony live
but in the meantime joe biden seems most
worried of all
joe biden is so panicked about what's
about to happen to ukraine he makes bill
crystal seem understated and restrained
and that's not really surprising because
joe biden is the president of the united
states he's got access to all the latest
intel it's delivered to him daily by the
weapons of mass destruction division at
cia those guys are on it
this week biden got so concerned after
reading what the cia delivered him
he's so worried about what's about to
happen to ukraine that joe biden called
the president of ukraine to warn him
about his fate
and then someone in the intel community
leaked the transcript of that call to
cnn not for the first time here it is
we have breaking news for you in our
world lead a senior ukrainian official
tells cnn that today's phone call
between president biden and ukrainian
president voldemort zolinski quote did
not go well
our source tells cnn that the two
disagreed about the immediacy of the
threat of a russian attack on ukraine
the white house and pentagon have been
emphatic that they believe an attack
could be imminent we should note the
white house just released its own
readout of that call and there was no
mention of president biden's warnings or
the two president's disagreements
whoa
first we should note that cnn is
perfectly capable of taking spin filled
propaganda calls
from agents of the ukrainian government
but you can't talk to russia because
that's treason but here's the headline
it looks like there is daylight between
the world's two closest leaders brothers
really
and that suggests there might be a
breach in the unbreakable bond forged
over centuries between ukraine and the
united states
listen to this from cnn's natasha
bertrand she did this reporting quote
per a senior ukrainian official biden
told president zielinski that a russian
invasion of ukraine is now virtually
certain and that kiev could be sacked
prepare for impact biden reportedly said
president zilinski disagreed and as i
reported asked him to tone down the
rhetoric
what
joe biden is more worried about russia
than the president of ukraine is
it looks that way
because not long after that reporting
cnn's natasha bertrand deleted that
tweet
oh and then an hour later cnn's jim
schutto contradicted cnn's own previous
reporting he tweeted out this white
house statement which had seen and
qualifies as reporting statement from
the white house here's what it said
white house on biden zielinski call
anonymous sources are leaking falsehoods
the only person who should be sacked is
the anonymous source was circulating an
inaccurate portrayal of this
conversation
end quote
not an actual denial therefore it's true
it's an amazing sequence really if you
think about it so biden tells the
ukrainian president that his capital
city is about to be sacked like rome in
the fifth century blood and screams fire
spears and swords seizures and
trebuchets a horrible scene
and ukrainians lead a response to this
calm down dude you're freaking me out
toughen up you sound like a terrified
old woman
now the white house claims that
conversation never happened but clearly
it did happen because at a press
conference today president zelinski said
virtually the same thing to the media
we've talked to the president we've
talked about this we think that it has
to be there has to be a balanced
approach i'm not saying that they he's
influencing uh american media they're
independent but
the media policy there has to be
well-balanced if they want to know what
the situation is that they they can come
to kiev do we have tanks on the street
no
the
image that mass media creates is that we
have troops on the roads we have
mobilization people are leaving for
places that's not the case we don't need
this panic
so david frum and joe biden have gotten
americans so whipped into a frenzy over
the future of ukraine that they're
flying to ukraine to risk their lives in
defense of that sacred nation
sovereignty
and there's the president of ukraine
saying we're not that concerned
so what can we infer from this well it's
simple if you're not terrified about the
prospect of a russian invasion of
ukraine the question is whose side are
you on here whose side are you on and we
know the answer to that question you're
on vladimir putin's side
so it looks like the president of
ukraine himself has been compromised by
russian misinformation
the ukrainian president is what we on
cable news refer to as an agent of putin
and that means the russians are so
diabolically effective they have
recruited the guy they're preparing war
against
how clever is that it would take a
slavic mind to pull that off and by the
way yes we are calling the president of
ukraine an agent of putin but we're not
judging him in fact we can relate we can
empathize because as you know if you
watch the media we're agents of putin
too
fox's chief propagandist tucker carlson
saying that the u.s should be siding
with russia over ukraine what you may
say members of congress are actually
getting phone calls encouraging them to
side with russia because they're
watching right wing media and people
like tucker carlson it is striking how
neatly kremlin propaganda seems to
dovetail with carlson's talking points
when tucker carlson delivers this
message it's dangerous now tucker seems
to have some sort of larger pattern here
with tyrants who lean to the right but
why is he so committed and why is fox
news
on his behalf so committed to tearing
down
american embrace and support and
alignment with the world's democracies
tucker is utterly shameless if he had
any capacity to feel any shame he should
be embarrassed by what he just said
because he is basically repeating
rank russian propaganda
mr max boot ladies and gentlemen in his
final domestic television appearance
before he heads to ukraine to defend
that nation himself its territorial
integrity from the aggression of
vladimir putin watch him while you can
but let's be clear about what the terms
are in the united states and this does
not apply to ukraine where they have
probably more sane view of it or maybe
just more russian influence view but in
the united states
if you raise any questions
about the wisdom of siding
in a war in eastern europe with one
country over another you are by
definition an agent of the single
greatest threats of democracy on this
globe mr vladimir putin himself
you're treasonous
congressman tom malinowski of new jersey
is claiming that viewers of this show
russian robots to a man
reached out to his office and did
something horrifying something probably
should be illegal they said maybe we
shouldn't go to war over ukraine
can you just tell us about these phone
calls that your office is getting
this yeah sure it really started
yesterday i was in my district office in
new jersey and
uh phones were ringing and my district
director
came to me and said i just spent an hour
on the phone with like four people
telling me that they'd watched tucker
carlson last night and
why are we going to be going to war for
ukraine russia's making reasonable
proposals for peace and we we should
just do what russia wants
yeah now a lot of people have said tom
malinowski
you know is not the sharpest drawer in
knife in the drawer right even by the
standards of new jersey however he makes
a really good point there are people out
there who look around
and decide
maybe i don't know homelessness close to
a million people living on the street in
the united states a hundred thousand
americans dying of drug ods inflation
the fact our schools haven't taught
anything in over two years
maybe these are more important concerns
than the territorial integrity of a
country we can't find on a map maybe our
own territorial integrity is more
important than ukraine's
and the question as congressman
malinowski raises is why would they ever
think that
where would they get the idea that their
stupid parochial domestic concerns are
more important than ukraine's eastern
border and the answer of course is
vladimir putin they've obviously fallen
for the russian propaganda
that would be us
doing vladimir putin's bidding
like the president of ukraine we're
guilty
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else